Rebecca Brandt voulait une chose pour son
anniversaire mon enfant veut un chat d'accord oui
passons à travers ça je suis un chat tu es le
meilleur cadeau que j'ai jamais eu j'ai toujours aimé
les chats je les ai toujours eu
Christopher Walken
il est juste couvert  chez les chats tout ce
film c'est hilarant les vidéos de chat sont
extrêmement populaires et nous avons beaucoup de
chats sur Internet dans ce film c'est mon
chat petits fans de bub bubs vous savez
qu'ils sont obsédés ou ils aiment dire bub
dit qu'elle répond à son nom hey  bubs je
ne sais pas si vous pourriez dire qu'il y a
tellement de récits de nous le voyant échouer un
saut
tout à coup un seul bras est là dans le
reste de son corps ce n'est pas le dernier vous
devez vous asseoir sur un clavier bloquant
parfois tout ce que vous avez envoyé  s'envoie
elle-même des e-mails, mais elle a reçu des e-mails, elle
me rappelle une diva célèbre qu'elle
ne veut pas poser pour des selfies avec des
gens, ils disent que la caméra ajoute 10
livres, c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé sérieusement du nom de
Pudge,
donc heureusement, Hamilton ne détruit pas
trop  à l'exception o  f juste des
rouleaux de papier toilette
s'il voit du papier toilette autour, il doit le
déchiqueter et il doit le faire aussi
vite qu'il le peut
Je ne sais pas ce que c'est
Christopher Walken est le
fan de célébrité numéro un des lauréats J'adore ces vidéos re
parler français c'est drôle et ces chats
sont géniaux je ne travaille pas avec eux
ces chats sont d'énormes stars je gâche plus de
prises que les chats courent
parfois les chats agissent en petite diva
SH mais ça allait c'était après la
caméra personne n'a vu  ça bouge c'est cloué